a new documentary series looking back at
the history of lgbtq+ representation on
television or lack thereof is now
available on Apple TV plus featuring
some of the queer communities biggest
celebrities visible out on television is
an important series we should all be
watching the earliest representations
were always people to be mocked people
couldn't be just who they were the truth
is there was no LGBTQ presence on TV
that I can remember when you see images
that are reflective of your own life
it's a reminder to you that your life
matters series features interviews with
celebs like Billy Porter Andy Cohen
Lena weaith Neil Patrick Harris Anderson
Cooper and many more and has them
opening up about what it was like to get
some representation on TV even if it was
from stray doctors at first you had Jane
Alexander and Jenna Rowland's they're
playing lesbians which is huge and I
know now you know we look at it and we
say well how come they couldn't cast
lesbians to play lesbians well there
weren't many out lesbians back there you
know so to have these straight actors
take on these roles to tell our story
that was that was pretty risk in in big
linear parts Star Trek Discovery's
Wilson Cruise is one of the executive
producers on the series and says the
show is about how TV was used as a way
to take back our stories and show what
it was like to be a member of the queer
community it's literally the story of
how television was used as a tool and
agent of change for the LGBTQ community
in a way for us to be able to tell our
stories and let this community this
country know who we actually are as
opposed to the vicious lies that we're
told about us or the demonic depictions
of us until we took a hold and took the
reins of course we cannot talk about
representation on television without
Ellen DeGeneres and her groundbreaking
coming-out episode of Ellen in 1997
why do I have to be so ashamed I mean
why can't I just see the truth I mean be
Who I am I'm 35 years old I'm so afraid
to tell people I mean
just Susan I'm gay
invisible out on television Allan shares
that her motivation behind pushing for
that storyline came from the shame that
she was feeling about keeping part of
herself hidden I was doing all this
meditation and deep soul-searching about
the shame that I was carrying because I
was gay and I thought if anyone knew
that I would lose my career and they
wouldn't like me anymore
I cried a lot and I realized how heavy
that shame was that I was carrying
around at the end of that week I called
the executive producers over to my house
and I told them that I wanted to come
out I still vividly remember watching
that episode so what is Wilson hope
viewers take away from the five-part
documentary series I hope that they take
away a sense of resilience that this
community has and that they're inspired
by it and continue to push the needle
forward especially in this moment when
so many people are feeling like they
need to do something I hope that this
series gives them the courage to step up
just like so many people on in this show
it did Wilson actually made history back
in 1994 when he became the first openly
gay actor to play an openly gay
character in a lead role on a major
American Network TV series with his role
on my so-called life I had this cost
colored shirt that was striped and I had
like hair sprayed my hair as high as I
possibly could and had my eyeliner on so
I walked in and I met with Mary Goldberg
the casting director and we did the
scene
and I started to walk out the door and
before I walked out I turned back to her
and I said I said I don't know if I'm
ever gonna see you again but please tell
whoever wrote this that it means a lot
to me that it would have made a
difference if I had seen this when I was
15 years old and she turned back and
said don't worry you're gonna be able to
tell her yourself
Wilson's character Ricci was such an
important character on television
watching my so-called life was the first
time that I felt represented on screen
and I'll never forget it
so will you be watching visible out on
television do you remember the first
time you felt represented on TV do you
think the entertainment industry is
doing enough to support the lgbtq+
community share your thoughts and
stories in the comments below oh hey
there if you want more LGBTQ news and
exclusive interviews click subscribe or
watch these videos